We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David P.
this is something a lot of people contacted
me about.
What exactly is wrong with Congressman Jim
Jordan?
Take a look at this.
Hi, David has gone Michael from Missouri.
I just got done watching these impeachment
inquiry videos.
And what is wrong with Jim, the gymnasium,
Jordan?
I mean, seriously, what, what's, what's wrong
with that guy?
I think that someone needs to get him, I don't
know, maybe a medical amount of [inaudible],
something like that.
The man seriously needs some help.
He, he is unhinged and it's interesting.
So, first of all, if you don't understand
the reference to Jim, Nate, Jim, gymnasium,
Jordan, I'm not going to mention it here because
I'd rather this video not get demonetized
and much like when you talk about a certain
person who was found dead under suspicious
circumstances in the last few months, your
video is the monetized.
If I told the gymnasium, gymnasium Jordan's
story, the video would also be the monetized.
So look up the gymnasium thing.
Yeah, I see Jim Jordan as an unhinged, a player
on the Republican side who believes himself
to be, and it is tricked a lot of people and
incisive and devastating questioner of the
left of witnesses who are critical of Donald
Trump.
And uh, his behavior is not just bizarre.
It's downright wacky.
And you can see this in any number of recent
hearings.
His physical appearance contributes to that.
And I don't know if that that's should or
should not be considered, but his physical
demeanor and appearance also just makes him
seem completely out of control.
Um, and uh, fortunately he has a cult following
on the right, but he's not really making much
of an impact.
This attempt to recently, at least in the
impeachment hearings, to try to derail the
testimony, um, have have fortunately not worked.
So continue keeping an eye on him, including
this week during the impeachment hearings.
Remember on black Friday, we will be sending
out an email to everybody on our newsletter
with a massive David Pakman show membership
special.
This is the last membership drive of the year.
If you've been thinking of becoming a member,
but you are waiting for a sweet discount and
get on our newsletter by signing up@davidpakman.com
and then on black Friday, next Friday, you
will be emailed with a super secret one time
use coupon code that you can use to get a
massive big lead, tremendous discount off
of membership.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will truck talk, by the way, about a prison
worker related to that person who died connected
to Trump suspiciously like a few months ago.
We will talk about that.
We will talk about Trump pardoning to service
members accused of war crimes, and we will
also talk about a very strange situation in
wa involving white castle and the suspension
of three judges.
All of those stories, and a possible upcoming
chess battle at the David Pakman show.
On today's bonus show, become a member or
a patron to get instant, the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.